we begin today
with an editorial
by the washington post
and just quickly a note on newspaper
lingo and lexicon there are op-eds or
columns in a newspaper op-eds are often
from outside sources someone's written a
piece
columns
generally come from a stable of
columnists who work at the newspaper
then there are editorials
which is the official position of the
newspaper and the editorial board
collectively
this and i'm about to read from is an
editorial
this is the official view of the
washington post's
editorial board
i saw the headline
and my jaw drop it is like
satire
there's gas lighting
and then there's this
from the washington post it's as if they
want to advertise to the country
dear america
pay us no attention pay us no heed we
are not to be trusted we are not serious
people and this is why our credibility
is in the toilet ready for this headline
republicans boast they have not pulled a
kavanaugh
talking about the current supreme court
hearings that wrapped up today
in fact
they've treated jackson
worse
it is the position of the washington
post
that republicans this week
have treated judge jackson worse
than democrats treated brett kavanaugh
in 2018.
now i was alive
and conscious in 2018 as were most of
you
and this assertion bears absolutely no
resemblance to reality
it is fantasy
it is gaslighting on steroids
here's part of what they write the
editors
of washington post throughout her senate
confirmation hearings judge katanji
brown jackson has been a model of
composure
which is made all the more impressive by
the egregious behavior of some of the
republican side
now
we can argue about whether the behavior
from some republicans amounts to
egregious i have disagreed with some of
their lines of argument
i think some of this is showboating and
grandstanding which you always see in
hearings like this
but to pretend as some insist upon
that this week was somehow out of bounds
or beyond the pale or really
awful
compared to how things normally go is
just simply
wrong
back to the editorial during the
hearings republicans such as senator
lindsey graham have congratulated
themselves for declining to treat judge
jackson the way democrats handled the
nomination of brett kavanaugh in fact by
the most relevant measures
i love that
mr graham and a handful of other
judiciary republicans have handled
themselves worse
really
a woman credibly accused mr kavanaugh of
sexual assault let's pause on that for a
moment no she didn't
dr blasey ford made an allegation
credibility is contingent upon evidence
there was no evidence there is no
evidence in fact there is precisely the
same amount of evidence
that judge katanji brown jackson
was engaged in an attempted sexual
assault as there ever was or is that
brett kavanaugh did anything of the sort
which is to say none
an allegation is not evidence
credibility must be backed up with proof
evidence contemporaneous or otherwise
and there is
none
backing any of the claims that were made
against brett kavanaugh i'll have more
to say about that in a moment since they
continue to insist on lying
about what happened in 2018 lying about
that case lying about kavanaugh lying
about the evidence they will not let it
go and for that reason neither will we
we will fact check them into oblivion
for the rest at least speaking on my own
behalf for the rest of my life if they
demand to continue with their lies
and the washington post editorial board
front and center
because it wasn't just democratic
activists and democrats in the senate it
was a lot of people in the media
journalists who were part of that mob
against kavanaugh
actively participating in it or cheering
it on rooting it on
and now people who are in the mob are
trying to tell the rest of us oh no
that wasn't so bad what's really bad is
what happened this week
to judge jackson
so they write a woman credibly accused
mr kavanagh of sexual assault no
evidence
democrats they write
rightly ask the committee to investigate
i'll remind you that this allegation was
not deemed credible by the chairwoman at
the time dianne feinstein she did not
see that it was relevant to bring up
in the hearings even in closed session
then some left-wing activists working
with their partners
staffers on the committee on the
democratic side they dropped these
allegations like a bombshell after the
hearings were over
in a very cheap trick stunt
a very dirty play
and the washington post was like oh they
just they just asked some questions they
just wanted to investigate after a
superficial fbi review
this is what the editorial claims a
superficial fbi review this was one of
multiple fbi background checks of brett
kavanaugh
i believe it was six or seven over the
course of his career
they wanted another review they got one
and the only thing that the fbi review
found in terms of new information was
that blasi ford's dear friend at the
time and her top witness
told the fbi that she was pressured to
lie to hurt brett kavanaugh by the
accusers allies
she said she and all the other supposed
witnesses at this alleged party
none of them said the party happened
none of them backed up the claims she
said
that they never seemed like they made
sense to her
and she has since told reporters this is
the friend leland kaiser that she does
not believe her friend christine blasey
ford she does not believe the story no
element of it is true and her allies
were bullying her behind the scenes to
get her to lie
to exaggerate
to perjure herself potentially in order
to achieve a political end against
kavanaugh which blasey ford's own lawyer
admitted later this was about abortion
jurisprudence they had political motives
so that's what the fbi investigation
actually found
it was bad information for the
accusations which is why they're
pretending that it really was just
superficial and didn't achieve anything
because it hurt the cause of the mob
in the end
the washington post editors write it was
mr kavanaugh who behaved intemperately
yeah he did he raised his voice he got
emotional you know why he's being
accused in front of the world of being
not just an attempted sexual assailant
in high school for which there is no
evidence but also a gang rapist a serial
gang rapist
that is what his wife was being dragged
through and his kids
this lunatic woman came out of nowhere
and said that kavanaugh was doing
gang rapes in the suburbs of dc
as a
teenager her story was completely false
totally fell apart
she was represented by michael avenatti
who's now in prison
there was not a shred
of evidence to support this insane
psychotic claim against brett kavanaugh
and yet at the time
just after julie swetnick and michael
avenatti trotted out this
just defamatory smear
and she did perjure herself on this
the whole thing
completely unraveled i will remind you
it was debunked
it was a giant disgusting lie
but senate democrats on that committee
all wrote a letter that day
saying because of this in fact i can
quote
following the release of a sworn
affidavit from julie swetnick detailing
new allegations of sexual assault by
brett kavanaugh all 10 democratic
members of the senate judiciary
committee today urged president trump to
immediately withdraw the nomination
chuck schumer joined in this insistence
he joined in the demand so you had every
democrat on that committee
who had the goal this week to talk about
comportment and civility and norms are
you kidding
all of them
plus schumer their leader in the senate
all seized upon the gang rape fantasy
from this crazy person and her now felon
lawyer
as a reason for kavanaugh to withdraw
but the real problem was brett kavanaugh
behaving intemperately
when people were accusing him on the
record of gang rape
by contrast this is the
washington post again republicans have
smeared judge jackson based on obvious
distortions of her record and the law
we've actually talked about some of this
i think some of the criticisms and
attacks and lines of inquiry were
misleading
i would not have endorsed or embraced
some of the things that republicans did
but at least they were talking about her
actual record they were talking about
her behavior her conduct her decisions
as a judge as a lawyer within the realm
of criminal justice they were not
talking about her high school drinking
habits
they were not asking him when she lost
her virginity
they weren't asking her that
they weren't asking about drinking games
they weren't talking about
her participation in conjured out of
nothing gang rapes
but it's the republican questioning this
week that the washington post says
that's really a bridge too far with
these disgraceful republicans worse than
kavanaugh worse
what an insult
these people think we have no memory
these people think we are morons
the editorial concludes neither side is
blameless in the politicizing of the
confirmation process but particularly
after they iced out then judge
merrick garland in 2016 republicans have
done the most damage
i could do an entire hour and in fact i
have years ago on this show
completely refuting that it is democrats
who have ratcheted up
this blood sport
on judicial confirmations for decades
starting with bork through to clarence
thomas all the way to kavanaugh
they escalate unilaterally time and time
again
the blockade of merrick garland was
using a democrat advocated tactic
with lots of obstruction that the
democrats pioneered themselves
and these tendentious ideologues
who have no respect for the facts or the
collective intelligence of the american
people at the washington post want us to
believe that the republicans are the
aggressors
that have done the most damage
when it comes to the way that these
confirmation battles play out wrong
and that what we just witnessed over the
last few days was worse than what the
democrats and their allies did
a few years ago to
now justice brett kavanaugh
what a crock of garbage
and i want to go down memory lane with
you
and just play some sound
from 2018 not that long ago we remember
it
it does not compare to anything that
happened this week
and we will get to some of those sound
bites as soon as we return
just getting started on the guy benson
show stay with us look i want to say
this i'll put up i'll put up her
credibility against donald trump's or
brett kavanaugh's any day of the week i
mean all of these women cannot be lying
i mean how many women are we up to now
that are accusing brett kavanaugh of
inappropriate uh conduct
i'm guy benson that was michael avenatti
on cnn with chris cuomo isn't that fun
back in 2018 saying he would put his
clients
credibility up against brett kavanaugh's
any day of the week well how's that
working out
his client
julie swetnick has been 100 discredited
she was lying about the gang rape
and all the democrats on the judiciary
committee embraced that smear
and used it to call on kavanaugh to
withdraw
kavanaugh
is a sitting associate justice on the
united states supreme court
and michael avenatti is a convicted
felon sitting in prison
remember this cory booker cut 15 during
the kavanaugh mess
i knowingly violated
the rules that were put forth i
understand that that the penalty comes
with potential ousting from the senate
i'm saying i'm knowingly violating the
rules okay senator cornyn how many times
out for it how many times do you learn
tell us yesterday i broke
these sham committee confidential rules
i accept full responsibility for what
i'm doing
absolute clown
he couldn't brag enough about how he was
breaking the rules
in order to
signal resistance against brett
kavanaugh remember the washington post
tells us
what republicans did this week far worse
kamala harris then a senator interrupted
the first sentence of the hearing
from chairman grassley started demanding
all sorts of
you know calls to order and an
opportunity to ask questions
interrupting grassley there were
protesters screaming and shrieking in
the gallery being dragged out constantly
how about this from sheldon whitehouse
mr white club cut 18. i don't believe
boof is flatulence i don't believe the
devil's triangle is a drinking game and
i don't believe calling yourself a
girl's alumnus
is being her friend
it was a disgrace it was one of the
worst things i've ever seen in our
politics and the washington post editors
have the gall to try to tell us that
this week was far worse
on behalf of the republicans get out of
here
that's a lie and it's self discrediting